So the U.S.
has now
confronted China
face to face over the suspected
Chinese spy balloon
shot down by the US two weeks ago.
And it happened Saturday
on the sidelines
of the Munich Security Conference
between US
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken
and Wang Yi, China's top diplomat.
Afterward, Blinken tweeted,
I condemn the incursion
of the PRC surveillance
balloon and stressed
it must never happen again.
China claims
a large balloon was
in fact a civilian research project
that crossed into U.S.
airspace by accident.
The US allowed it to float
through the country
for several days
before shooting it down
off the coast of South Carolina.
On Saturday,
Wang was asked to comment on the downing
of the balloon.
Here's what he said
We asked the United States to handle it
calmly and professionally
based on consultation with
the Chinese side.
Regrettably,
the United States disregards these facts
and use advanced
fighter jets and downed a balloon
with its missiles.
This is, I would say,
absurd and hysterical,
absurd and hysterical.
CNN's
Nic Robertson is covering the conference
for us in Munich.
And CNN's
Mark Stewart is standing
by for us in Tokyo with more from there.
Nic, to you first.
The meeting between Blinken and Wang
was contentious for sure,
but did it clear the air
in terms of serving to reestablish
an important dialog for both countries?
Well, I think the language
that's been used subsequently
by the State Department,
not calling it a spy balloon,
avoiding that kind of language
for the Chinese is inflammatory
because, of course, they deny
that it was a spy balloon.
It was meteorological
balloon.
That's that's what they've been saying.
But, look, I think that President Biden
has taken a huge amount
of domestic political heat
over this, particularly
because the balloon was allowed
to fly across the United States before
it was shot down.
The administration has been very strong
and very clear
that it did this
because it believed that
to shoot the balloon down
above the United States could potentially
spray debris or cause debris
to fall down
and potentially injure
people on the ground.
So I think the language
that we're hearing
from Secretary of State
Blinken, this very strong
condemnation of China's
balloon entering U.S.
airspace, a violation of sovereignty,
breaking international law.
That's an indication
of the tough response that,
if you will, politically demanded
in the United States.
Diplomatic as well.
Yes, but there's
there is a political element to this.
But I think some of the other language
has also been very tough,
a very tough warning for China about
if it further supports
Russia and its war in Ukraine.
Concerns were raised here by
by the vice president and by six
time state
Blinken with allies
telling their European partners
that they're concerned
that China is has a disturbing
trend line
towards upping its support for Russia.
That this is
it appears that China can be
sort of walking up to a line
that it might cross
whereby it will give military support to
to Russia.
And that's a concern.
And there were strong warnings
in the meeting about that.
And we will get to
that issue in a minute.
I want to go to Mark,
though, in Tokyo
just to talk about China's
reaction to this.
We know China is reasserting itself
on the global stage
now that it seems of its claims
it's conquered COVID.
But what could this mean for us?
China relations going forward
Well, I mean, as you well know, Paula,
we may never know the true scope
of the COVID situation.
The impact on people in China
and that's based off of what
we have heard
from the World Health Organization.
It's based off of what we've heard
from medical experts.
We also know
that China has had
a lot of economic hardship
because of COVID.
I'm talking about supply chain
issues, manufacturing,
even the stress on local governments,
quite frankly,
in order to have economic success
You need diplomatic success.
And both
the United States
and China are invested in each other.
Perhaps this declaration is saying,
yes, China is open for business,
but to perhaps it is leaving some room
for some more diplomatic,
political negotiations.
At least
that may be one way
to interpret this, Paula.
And it seemed
that they
had to at least come face to face
on this issue
before they could go on the others.
I want to go back to something
Nic was alluding to.
I want you to hear now from Wang himself
talking about Ukraine. Let's listen
We need
to think calmly, especially our friends
in Europe.
About what efforts should be made
to stop the warfare.
What framework
should there
be to bring lasting peace to Europe?
So, Nick,
how was those kinds of comments
received by both Europe
and the United States, especially since,
as you mentioned,
the US is now coming out with its theory
that, look,
we believe that China may attempt
to materially
support Russia
in its conflict with Ukraine.
You know, I think they're being treated
with skepticism.
I think they're being treated with
actions are going to speak louder
than words.
And and
following on from those comments,
that Wang Yi
made that he went on to say that
legitimate security concerns
must be addressed in this in this deal.
And I think to European and us is
that sounds like saying that Russia's.
Russia's pretext,
President Putin's pretext
for invading
Ukraine that he was concerned
about NATO's expansion,
although he has gone in and killed
thousands upon thousands of Ukrainians
and destroyed
much of the infrastructure
in the country.
That that this does not align
with what
the Europeans in the US understands
with the real reasons for Putin's
rationale to go into Ukraine.
So when China says
legitimate security concerns
must be addressed.
It will sound very much
as if it's sort of taking Russia's
corner on this.
And this was part of the message
that the White House
and the State Department were spreading
among allies here,
that on the one hand,
it may appear that
China is speaking about peace moves
and that it may be making these overtures
about being a sort of a peace broker.
But behind the scenes,
they are quietly increasing their support
for Russia.
Now, it has to be clearly said
that there is no evidence
that's being put forward
that Russia
that China is giving
military aid to Russia.
It would be a game changer.
And I spoke yesterday
with the European
Commission President
Ursula von
der Leyen,
and I asked her about this
particular issue
and she said
this is something we're concerned about.
It's an open issue on the table.
She said
whether or not or what level of support
China is giving to Russia.
But it's certainly something
that European nations
are concerned about.
And Jens
Stoltenberg,
NATO's secretary
general, spoke
about it as well yesterday.
Yeah, everyone seemed to be quite candid.
And given
that Mark is expected, in fact,
to travel to Russia in the coming days,
what's the expectation there
especially since China has made it clear
it wants to strengthen
its bond with Russia,
at least economically
and strategically in its own sphere.
Right.
And I think just to pick up on
also what
Nick was saying, this
this idea that that that China
is publicly saying it's for peace,
but privately doing something else.
I mean, a lot of those allegations
are being made
based off of you with US intelligence.
That's what
the State Department is saying.
And that it is sharing
those those intelligence findings
with with with their counterparts
in the E.U.
I think moving forward,
China has been given a very firm warning,
at least
according to a State
Department spokesperson,
that if it does pursue these channels,
there will be consequences.
There will be ramifications.
I mean, I think that's the big takeaway,
at least from the State Department
towards China is saying
China take notice, were warning you now.